it's the world's largest swamp but the
Sud in South Sudan suddenly state is now
home to 28 year-old Deborah acquiesce
she fled her home in leer town several
kilometres away because of fighting
Deborah now struggles to feed herself
and her children neuquén but it's in
right now we cannot do farming because
of insecurity if you take a risk and go
home you may lose your life what makes
me lose sleep is that during the rainy
season we farm on and off because of
displacement floods also destroy our
crops we really suffer during the rainy
season due to lack of shelter Deborah
and her kids are now among the 7.5
million people out of South Sudan's 11
million population who rely on food aid
years of fighting that started in 2013
and was largely brought to an end after
a deal in 2018 resulted in nearly 4
million people being displaced many had
to abandon their farms which has led to
food shortages and last November's
floods have made worse an already dire
situation the UN's World Food Program
says more than half of the 27 flood
affected counties are facing extreme
levels of acute malnutrition but
delivering aid in a poor country like
South Sudan is not easy bad roads mean
air drops have become the only way to
reach many in remote areas like Niall
where Deborah has taken refuge there's
also the risk of famine we need to be
supporting five and a half million
people in South Sudan with some form of
food assistance but if we don't get the
resources to reach that many people
we're going to have to make some really
tough choices we're gonna have to focus
on alleviating the most food insecure
people in the country staving off hunger
stopping that famine in its tracks but
that also means that some people will
fall through the gap it means we won't
be able to support everybody children
are the most at risk from the lack of
food here all their families can do now
is hope that somehow they get the help
they need
Hiba morgan al-jazeera